yeah welcome again to a new video before
I could get another Sicilian here and
yeah it's a five-minute game I'm should
say this at least once okay you see it
and with a clock time and another skaven
in here I headed to just just one that
has one just before and this guy's also
from Spain maybe this is the same guy
right just just with another handle this
this possible could be all right I play
for to prevent any beef I firm stuff um
and I play this yeah by ESO to say I
don't don't know the theory that well
this this opening rookie ATM this is
also normal think ship here
hmm yeah the SSD for there are these g4
ideas I'm not sure how this is played
usually white retreats the night at some
point would be three but he waits until
Bishop d7 is happening at least from the
games that i know so i can i play g4
immediately is this possible orgy form
if it takes well c'mon let's try it
cannot them make a correspondence gamer
out of this looks a bit weird it to be
honest to play this so early
or do you play Queen d2 maybe instead of
bougie form cannot show at all let's
check quickly what you can do now if you
place night XD form and think I'll take
with the bishop should be an okay if
I've I have most likely Bishop 80 k play
something entirely different a voluntary
voluntarily retreat okay I'd want to
take and then play b6 so should I am
actually retreat the night myself I
could do this not be 3 or play g5 Oki
Kenji 5m
so if I go if I played very
straightforward like f5 this too
straightforward well I cannot take
really because some take on f5 I mean 95
would be terrible come on not quite sure
if I have some sub x um again I've have
some some deep maneuvers here maybe just
play it in a straightforward style g2 or
why should I go to maybe ito to keep see
foursquare covered could be better but I
like the idea of Bishop g2 covering this
long diagonal mmm well I don't need to
move it I could also go Bishop to g5
here
oh come on let's let's retreat this
first I think I need this piece also for
my own team protection he goes Knight c4
I would play Bishop c1 don't mind that
so much ok so maybe Queenie to jump on
the iphone not so sure I play f6 I mean
I'm burying his Bishop but it's hard to
believe that I can actually check matin
ok but at least it's a space space
gainer here now he will have play on the
queenside no doubt about that
yeah what are my own plans cannot play
really h4 h5 made him on the edge farm
dr quite unrealistic really but still
it's not dumb super easy for black to to
make progress I hope normal / being our
Bishop d7 lv6 Bishop d7 and night see
Foster just straightforwardly attacking
this Bishop which would need to drop
back to see one mmm well it seems here
needs to take his time here I actually
think it is also not bad for him to
exchange one night he sort of has two
nights for one square only five it's a
bit of a case of those this superfluous
piece okay so really h4 h5 here maybe
need to get something going here the
center still looks rather stable
and he takes this time really okay I
don't think there's much threatening at
the moment on e form this is why I
wanted to keep the bishop on g2 why not
move it somewhere else to always have a
form protected ok so I just need a queen
2h7 and his checkmate this is a good
news the bad news is how how do i
actually do this go into h7 simple chest
maybe just just here and now try a queen
e to F to something okay is opening up
the position time morning this is always
a possibility for black try to counter
in the center oh that's an interesting
idea interesting move ok ok I want one
to pin the snide
the spinner looks all right quite
annoying so now still I just need to
look on the edge for Quinn 2h7 and
rather simple but may be effective line
has worked I'll write some more pressure
here all right I just play rook h3 now
look h3 and stuff like this don't think
you can take me to all right he might
have rook do one as a potential
counterplay so maybe just here yeah this
is a pin oh this is a pin also cool very
ugly I were too stupid oversight getting
into this
I can just take terrible check checkmate
yeah with this was so rather unnecessary
I think black is just just been in this
position cannot believe this well the
computer like some black actually mm-hmm
all I should be worse this is close to
impossible don't think this ok let's
should share this check here computer
once back to see one and gives black
slight advantage am well the computer
has good nerves yeah maybe yes enough
counter play my king is open as well
possible now queen edge to is just
winning all this is so no surprise
really I mean can't believe this King on
G idea the post not possible Queen age
to write Queen h2 plus iater just queen
age 6 mm okay yeah at Queen h2h two
years just just bad but this is already
better for black according to the
computer now you can really trust the
comp in this position that's pure calc
no strategy no nothing just calculation
and is losing yeah I need to play Queen
h2 here and queen age 6 is just done
just curtains I guess if he gives a
check I just go here and in just nothing
here what about this move I can go here
and protect g5 yeah my king is wide open
also move like this we can just take
and Queen h6 just just wins here this
night is protecting this this essential
check square where black might get
somewhat encounter play alright so we
are really spoiled it here tweenage to
would have been very nice at the whole
position was of course I'm very very
difficult to handle yeah yeah it's
possible that blacks counterplay in the
center is very strong here computer
actually wants to play Knight c4 with
quite a big advantage but Sir it's
possible no no no question I mean he's
got everything in the center and I spend
lots of time your help on moose alright
thanks for watching